[Applause]
dimensional beings go
[Music]
well obviously we've got three
dimensions we're living in but they've
proven
these spectrometers that nasa has
there's dark matter that's five times
more powerful than the matter we're
living in
and so there is an outside force that's
why even the head of bank of america
said
we're held captive by some outside force
so these guys that tell you there's no
god there's no devil there's no
spiritual stuff going on
that's just ancients realizing there's
more than what we can see
in the limited band of our vision it's
like not even one percent
right of what's happening and so there
are multi-dimensions
we can understand three dimensions yeah
but it's proven that there's more than
three dimensions
that's right right like space is a
fourth dimension there's 12 dimensions
right okay so and i guess the idea of
understanding space is a fourth
dimension is like
if you kept on going that way in space
eventually you would wrap around
yes back to where you were and then
there's a fifth dimension a six
dimension etc
so you think that there are beings that
exist
in more than the three dimensions that
we exist in that's right like an
elevator they're
they're able to go up and down what do
you mean by that well you know you've
got to
explain to us dummies that don't
understand well no i mean definitely
there are aliens don't come here on
spaceships from a trillion miles away
they they're interdimensional wormholes
whatever you want to call it
and the mathematics shows that they're
able to come into our dimension leave
our dimension
and that the third dimension is kind of
a base launch pad
of the basics of the higher dimensions
and so the third dimension is is the
first dimension
that has real intelligence and and is
able to evolve
okay and so we kind of live on the basic
plane
of everything that's built at the
foundation and then as you
increase in dimensions you increase in
technology that allows you to explore
them
is that yes but here's the problem plato
2
300 years ago the big greek philosopher
wrote a bunch of stuff they dug up that
was true like he said troy was over here
this was over there but he said out in
the atlantic ocean there was a big base
that had flying machines
the an unlimited power a big white light
source
but it blew up was it hydroelectric was
it nuclear we don't know
we said there were flying machines all
over the world he'd try the worlds
around
well how did a guy in greece know that
well he had the documents he had the
original source code
and so that's what we're saying is is
that there's a lot of hidden technology
a lot of hidden history on this planet
our planet itself
is more like just a jumping off point
and it's not just for us there's a lot
of stuff that comes through here
and we're kind of like in the middle of
a major traffic jam
with just entities and and systems and
and ideas so do we have access to any of
this technology
has any of this technology permeated the
things that we use
i think so look at all this so this is
alien technology
in its most rudimentary levels i like
transformers i've seen
transformers yeah it's like the
all-spark that's how we got our
technology
that's all this [ __ ] shia labeouf knows
the cube
yeah the cube before there was cybertron
yeah
that's your voice
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]
no but you just said it and so we all
know it what was the question before
[Laughter]
before we came to your planet we battled
on cybertron
my name is megatron sounds hell or like
optimus prime it's
crazy right yeah it's like exhausting i
just said it so we all know it
what was the question
andrew schultz prepare for battle yeah
oh we are okay so we have access to some
of this alien technology right
spark all sparks before there was
cybertron there was the cube
now people like let's say uh your boy
elon musk
your fellow austin native you guys get
along he has access to the cube
yes he does do you think he's been given
certain information or has figured out
certain information that the rest of us
don't know
yes it's clear elon musk is working with
megatron
[Laughter]
and is he trying is he like part alien
is he
i believe elon musk is part of an alien
invasion of earth
and what do they want ultimately no i
like him
this movie trailer was awesome to be
honest with you does elon
finally on the schultz broadcast
alien technology is delivered yes it
does now
what does um guy colon feel like
[Laughter]
let's get started
[Laughter]
elon musk alien technology
interventional beings
how do you have proof of this it's not
just actually
elon musk is my baby
he's doing he's thinking about danny
glover when he grabs me
[Laughter]
megatron prepare for battle yeah
no let's get serious yeah yeah let's
talk about it
um no we are creatures that live here
have a very limited spectrum of color
and light that's it
yeah and so everything i'm not putting
this down but we get this
but they now know as spectrometers and
all the mathematical analysis they're
stuck below us and above us and all
around us
so that's why it's such a joke it's all
about energy it's about so who has
access to this
who love us and who the [ __ ] are they is
nancy pelosi a globalist like
the name of a say she's a a cog in the
machine
like like when you have like a one of
those games you put money in like grabs
a ball out or a ball out
she's like a claw that just goes down no
no the the problem is that globalists
want
mindless machines so when you see a
chuckie schumer and nancy pelosi or
these people
they are zombies of the system trump had
problems he wasn't perfect
but they were pissed at him because
trump was being trump they didn't like
trump because he was actually being
himself
um and that's why you supported him i
mean i supported him because i supported
him early on
i knew he wasn't a globalist he wasn't
perfect but yeah i got persecuted for
supporting trump they had a video out
last week going
leaked video of jones saying he hates
trump it was a film i was in
it's all lighting i'm in there in a
chair yeah and i'm like you know
if i wasn't a moral person to just care
to myself i'd say [ __ ] trump
trump was a [ __ ] [ __ ] he ruined my
[ __ ] life everything got horrible
after trump i took my bank accounts away
sued me [ __ ] took my sponsors away
but i still support trump because he did
the right thing
they edit that part off so that's what
they do it's just like it's like you
know
like why don't you answer for attacking
trump
it's all fraud interventional beings
well if you go back to satanism
they kill children and they rape women
they do all these bad things believing
in all the main literature main history
give not your children to the fires of
molech whether it was
ancient asia or ancient middle east or
ancient africa ancient america ancient
europe
every culture went into a decline and
started sacrificing children
normally on a pyramid to an entity and
so i i liken it to these videos i've
seen on youtube that have hundreds of
millions of views
of people in the caribbean very close
here in florida
who go every day and feed tiger sharks
some rotten fish
and so they show up all the time and so
i liken that to this that
they sacrifice children like every day
on an altar
interdimensionally these priests take
dmt and other
ayahuasca hallucinogens to get rid of
the veil when the brain blocks all this
because you're not supposed to see all
this you go crazy
and these things only swim up like
you're feeding fish in a pond when you
kill a kid
or you torture somebody so that's why
satanists take drugs to end the veil
and then they torture a child on top of
pyramid
at certain sites and the more you kill
children at certain sites
you're not going to wait until five kids
for one show up the minute you pull that
knife out the demons show up
and so for the average human they are
projecting another dimension
they think this must be a god higher
dimensional creatures would not do
something like this
but if you're there slitting children's
throats
cutting their hearts out germans did it
the babylonians did it
you know mesoamerica did it every
culture did it you're doing this because
you know these things show up
and then you're on hallucinogens so
they're able to mind meld with you
and they give you ideas like a wheel
might be good fire might be good
and so these things want coin that it's
children being murdered
so they want the interdimensional pain
of the shoulder interdimensional pain of
the children
brings them to you you are on these
drugs
it allows you to communicate with them
and through that communication they give
you these
what often happens to be creative ideas
inspirational
so the iphone has to be made in a
sweatshop
that's why we have childhood people that
run this are evil because here's the
deal
you're not just getting ideas from these
aliens these are lo these are bad aliens
you are interfacing with them so it's
their template you're not just taking
their technology
when you like graham grimoire and black
magic books
for the middle ages you pay a demon gold
or it pays you to kill a kid
you then interface with that demon so
you think this whole satanic ritual is
that what happened no
the truth was there's something more
complex interdimensionally you become a
slave
so whatever they're doing is not even
the picture
like you think oh i killed a kid i got
power that was a fake transaction you
killed a kid
you released god's protection of you now
you're under its control
us you do believe that god protects us
why is why is child sacrifice the
cash-in like why is that the trade why
can't it be
some other type of trade because the
most valuable thing on this planet is
our children
and if you will piss on your children
and you'll cut them up for some other
entity to get power
you'll do anything wait can i just get a
little biblical on our ass right now
wasn't who was it who was it there was a
martin
killed his kids who was about to say
abraham abraham was about to
sacrifice isaac no and god got that god
said
you he said kill and then god said don't
do it the angel held his hand and said
there's a ram kill that
which that'd be like a week full of meat
so it's again exactly it's the same deal
before every culture african latin
american
german every culture white black old
young you killed kids to the deity
and god said in the abrahamic religion
it stops now you stopped killing your
kids you know
i was in uh that's heavy stuff you're a
smart guy
you